hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
single cell sequencing to investigate
epigenetic mechanisms in
inflammatory lymphocytes i am jen woods
of lab roots and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
illumina and dolomite bio for more
information
about our sponsor please visit their
website
at illumina.com and dolomitebio.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen i'd like
to now introduce our presenters
dr thomas ayers dr powell sajak
and dr adam kribs for a complete
biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr ayers you may now begin your
presentation
so hello everyone uh my name is thomas
ayers i'm a technical application
specialist for dolomite bio
dylamite bio is a company which is
dedicated to providing
microfluidic solutions for single cell
biology
and today i'll be taking you through
just some sort of groundwork so that
we're all on the same level when it
comes to knowing about single cell rna
sequencing
so that when we get into the real meat
of dr adam cribs research
we all know what we're talking about so
first of all i'd like to go through
single cell rna sequencing from the
perspective of performing it
with uh microfluidic devices so that we
can do so in very very high throughput
this abbreviates to scr and ac
so what i'll be talking about here is
how the work
uh for single cell rnaseq some of that
has been performed on the nadia platform
uh within the paper that adam cribbs is
about to present
so i'll go through the workflow now of
single cell rna seq on this nadia
platform using microfluidics
first of all we start as with most
single cell workflows
um by making sure that we have cells
with very very high viability
and cells which are adequately
dissociated from each other so that they
can be
separated into single compartments from
here
we move on to the aspect which is
performed on
the microfluidic device aka the nadia or
the nadia innervate
and what we do there using this
microfluidic junction in the center
is that we are flowing cells within cell
buffer
and oligo dt capture beads within
cell lysis buffer together into a
microfluidic
junction which is then cut off by a very
high speed oil jet
into individual droplets this happens at
around
anywhere between 1000 and 2000 drops per
second and so we can get very very high
throughput from this
the result of this is that we end up
with droplets containing
just one cell and just one of those
beads and on those beads we have
many many oligos which contain a barcode
sequence the same for every
bead sorry the same for every oligo on
one bead so that we can later identify
which reed is coming from which cell
indeed
and also we have on each of those oligos
a poly dt
capture tail so that we can capture the
polyadenylated mrna the next step of
this process which also occurs on the
nadia
platform is that we undergo cell lysis
within those droplets so we're breaking
the cell open
breaking out the mrna and the mrna then
binds to the poly t
tails of the bead at this point with
scrnacon nadia
we do something very special which is
when we break open the droplets
and take all of those beads into uh
basically a bulk situation in a tube so
that we have all of those beads with all
of the mrna captured on it
and all sitting together at which point
we can go on to the next steps
of library preparation library
preparation involves basically doing
reverse transcription to generate cdna
and then amplifying a library off of
that using pcr
then we can use different fragmentation
kits like
such as the xterra kit provided by
illumina
to make these libraries compatible with
next generation sequencing devices
which pavel will go more into later
after which
we have all of the read information
necessary to undergo all of our
complicated bioinformatics
and take all of that information
decide which cell which read came from
which transcripts are produced the most
and we can create some very interesting
diagrams to do with
what kind of cell types come out of your
particular tissue of interest
so that would be the workflow of general
scrnaseq
on nadia but what we can go through just
quickly now is an ideal product family
and how it is unique in terms of a
microfluidic droplet-based
fluidic device there are a few different
unique aspects to this
the first of which is our proprietary
technology here
which we have proprietary stereo drives
within
the chip itself this is where we have
magnetic stirrers
within the cell and bead reservoirs
ensuring that all of our cells and beads
are fully suspended in solution for the
entire run
you can imagine if we've got the cells
coming through in clumps where they've
sunk
during that microfluidic process that
can result in doublets
so the stereo drives on the nadia are
there to prevent that
we also work with three independent
pressure pumps for cells beads and oil
so that we can do some quite interesting
things later on to do with changing
pressure levels to like account for
different mufflers and things like that
if your cells are happy in different
parts
and finally throughout this entire
process on the nadia uniquely
for a microfluidic droplet-based device
we have temperature control using a
peltier drive
allowing us to keep the cells and mrna
at four degrees avoid mrna degradation
maintain transcriptome state
throughout that entire process this
temperature control can also go up to 40
degrees but that's really becomes
interesting with
other different kinds of applications
which you can read about on our website
so overall we know that with the nadir
instrument we can use those standardized
protocols for str and asyk
in order to generate a high throughput
single cell transcriptomes using that
application and using that workflow
we can do so with scalability up to
eight samples at the time
and we have various other benefits
coming from the fact that we're using
those
microfluidic chips which are disposable
themselves
just very briefly what i'll do is i'll
move on to
the added module for the nadia innovate
so this is an add-on which sits beside
that nadia machine which i've just shown
you
and effectively what that allows us to
do is to port the pressure
from those three precise pumps from the
nadia
into a single chip and we can view
the dropletization process of creating
droplets and flowing cells and beads
into them
in real time using the high speed
digital microscope camera
what this allows us to do with the
integrated flow control software is that
we can
play with different settings to do with
pressure to do with temperature
and to do with stirrers to see whether
we can maybe improve
on the microfluidic aspect so if you've
got let's say
big cells we can decrease oil rate
things like that in order to get the
droplets bigger
if you've got cells which are only happy
in a particularly sticky buffer
something which happens
a lot when you get towards niche cell
types then we can account for that
buffer thickness by altering the
pressure levels
of those different buffers what this
allows us to do basically
is to open up the entire system um
to optimization of existing protocols so
we can take that scrnace protocol that
i've just talked about
tweak it to make it best for your
particular cell type
or we can even create entirely new
protocols or
uh single cellify existing bulk
protocols and things like that
and we can do so uh in real time using
that
high-speed digital microscope camera and
that we can then port these protocols
back onto the nadia system
to run in an automated way with up to
eight samples at a time
so without further ado i will now move
on to and
allow paddle to take over where he'll
take over the park
downstream from encapsulating those
droplets
and through to the aspect that takes
place on sequences once we have a
sequenceable library
so over to you pavel
thank you very much
tom for this great introduction to
the dolomite biotechnology and to the
single cell sequencing workflow
so as mentioned my name is pavel sayak
i'm part of illumina's marketing team
and it's my great pleasure to within the
next five minutes present who we are
what we do and a couple of our recent
news
so for those of you who haven't heard
about illumina we are a global company
and we develop manufacture and market
innovative next generation sequencing
and microarray technologies
and our technology enables you to make
foundational discoveries
to transfer medicine and ultimately to
impact
lives and today there are more than 200
000 publications where our technology
has been used it clearly shows that this
is a robust technology that you can
trust
and there are two ways in which you can
get access to this technology you can
either purchase a system
implement it in-house in your own lab or
you can turn to one of the many service
providers that are available
and get access to our technology there
and as mentioned one of the technologies
we offer is next generation sequencing
and it is a single technology but it
unlocks a wide range of applications
a wide range of biological insights so
the sequencer can be seen as a tool
and depending on how you prepare the
sample you can use it to study many
different
facets of biology so if you take for
example look at the
cancer research you can of course use
sequencing to perform single cell
analysis as a
singles analysis topic of this
particular webinar
but you can also do tumor mutation
profiling figure out what
differentiates the tumor from normal
tissue you can study the microbial
component to study the interplay between
this component
and tubers so a single technology but
unlocking a wide range of
applications
and we provide sequencing systems that
enable a wide range of single cell
applications so no matter which
biological modality you're interested in
no matter if you're interested in doing
a global study for example studying the
entire transcript home or if you want to
zoom in on a particular subset of
transcripts
we do have a sequencing solution that
fits your output needs
and it's exactly the same with study
size so from small studies to very large
studies
we are more than happy to support you
with sequencing part
and here we also show our portfolio of
sequencing platforms
so on the left hand side you see the
iseq 100 that's our
smallest most affordable benchtop system
and with 4 million reads it's
too limited for the majority of single
cell applications
but it's a really good fit for quality
control of libraries before you run them
on one of the larger
systems on the right hand side we have
the nova c6000 that's our production
scale sequencer for those large studies
and what i wanted to introduce now is
our
latest sequencer the nexiq 2000
which allows deep large studies but
still within a benchtop
platform so there is a lot of innovation
that has gone
into the nexic 2000 so it clearly shows
our long-standing tradition of
technological advances
and all these innovations translate into
significant gains
for example there is a two times
reduction in operating costs
uh compared to the nexiq 550 instrument
and the output has been increased from
400
million that you get with 400 million
reads that you get with the next 550
to 1 billion reads on 2000.
so opening up for those larger and
deeper and wider studies
and we have tested the nexiq 2000 on a
wide variety of different library types
and it gives the the same high quality
data that you've come to expect from
illumina
so for example if you take a look at the
the figure to the right
you see that there is a really strong
correlation between
the nexiq 550 and x2004 mrnaseq
libraries so the same high quality data
that you've come to expect
from illumina
our production scale sequencer the next
sorry the nova 6000
it has also seen continuous innovation
since it was launched in 2017
and a couple of months ago we released
the latest
version of the reagents for this
instrument and they are called version
1.5
and these carry a number of gains
so one of them is an is a reduced price
which means that you can sequence more
with the same budget
so this once again opens the door for
those larger deeper
broader studies for example if you want
to add them
modality to your existing single-cell
experiments
and in addition the consumers also have
a greater flexibility
improved robustness and enhanced use of
experience
and one example is that the shelf life
has been increased from three months
to six months
and with this i wanted to to thank you
for your attention and i encourage you
to get in touch with us
so if you are planning a single cell
sequencing experiment
don't hesitate to get in touch so that
we can have a discussion
and propose to you the best sequencing
solution
for that particular project so with
this i wanted once again thank you for
your attention and i will now
turn uh turn the presentation to dr adam
kripsta the star of the show
please take it away adam
thank you paul morning afternoon and
evening
i'm adam i'm group leader in systems
biology at the botner research center
within the university of oxford
and i need a computational biology team
with a broad interest in systems biology
immunology and epigenetics today i would
like to give you an overview on
how we've been using single cell
transcriptomics to understand
more about the role of jumanji histone
demethylases within the immune system
so the first thing to mention is that i
have no disclosures
unfortunately for me but fortunately for
you i'm not being paid to deliver this
talk
therefore i can talk very openly about
my own research but also i'm happy to
provide questions on the application of
the technology we've been using to
address some of these scientific
questions
so just as a bit of a quick background
to myself so
my background is actually as a molecular
immunologist um i undertook my phd
um at the kennedy institute of
rheumatology but during my postdoc
i actually started to generate large
amounts of sequencing data and i
realized that i had
none of the skills to analyze any of the
data
and so i ultimately relied on other
people within the group and not having
ownership over my own
science or the ability to analyze the
data was actually the most frustrating
time i've ever experienced in my
scientific career
and this ultimately acted as a catalyst
for me to successfully apply for a
fellowship to completely retrain in
computational biology with professor
chris ponting
also within the university of oxford and
it was actually here that i developed
advanced skills in a number of
statistics software development and data
analysis that have allowed me to
undertake
large-scale data-driven projects
so now i'm actually leading my own
computational research group
and the focus has definitively shifted
towards single cell
within the past two years or so so
colleagues and myself
have been involved in developing novel
single cell methodologies
um both wet lab and on the computational
side and unfortunately i won't have time
to go into that today
but i also lead the computational
component of the tendon seed network
which is part of the human cell atlas
project
and coordinate the computational
analysis teams involved in applying
single cell sequencing to multiple
myeloma clinical trials
more recently i've been involved in
working in a large team of scientists
playing a small role but an important
role within the
single cell immune profiling of covet
samples as part of a
larger combat consortium within the
university of oxford
um however what i'd like to speak to you
today
about is how we're actually using single
cell sequencing as a tool to investigate
epigenetic research specifically in this
talk i want to give you an overview of
the single cell technologies
um that we work with an overview of
maybe some of the
quickly over the positives and negatives
of each and then i'll introduce our
computational strategy we take to
analyze the data
um then using an example
um of the jumanji student dimethylase
recent published work i'm going to show
you how we can use single cell
technologies
applied as a research tool within to
answer scientific
research questions
um initially i'm going to give an
overview of the single cell sequencing
state of play within our laboratory
we have essentially three systems
um which we routinely run within our
laboratory the first is smartseek2
which is a well-based approach where
single cells are fact sorted into
individual wells
in plates and then chemistry takes place
within those individual wells
the two other systems are droplet-based
approaches this is the nadia system
which tom
introduced before and the 10x chromium
system
so each technology is applied really to
address
different scientific questions and each
technology has its own
different quirks and advantages and
disadvantages over the other
so when you look at uh well actually i
suppose the
question that i get asked routinely by
members of the group
um is which technology should i use to
answer my research question
and the answer isn't actually always
that easy to
simply address however when you compare
droplet-based
systems against smart sig-2 or actually
many other well-based approaches the
issue that you will always find is that
there's a trade-off between cell number
and the numbers of genes detected in
your analysis
the cost of smart seek 2 and the fact
that it can be a very manual process
means that smart c2 cost per cell is
very high
although it gives you superior
resolution in terms of the gene
expression so it's quite
high depth in terms of the numbers of
genes
when comparing nadi antennas the
comparison is
pretty much always due to cost versus
cell numbers versus the ease of protocol
firstly the main thing is that the
principles between dropseek
and 10x are very similar with slightly
different executions
the nadia system is around half as
expensive as 10x
so it allows us to actually perform more
sequencing experiments
however the protocol is ever so slightly
more hands-on for dropseek
and another factor is that to generate
good drop seek experiments you typically
require more
input cells and i think in our lab at
the moment
i would reckon around about 70 to 80
actually run on the nadia system um and
the rest on on 10x we
at the moment very rarely doing
smartseek2 because of the low throughput
in the cost
so the single cell workflow is very
simple when you compare it to
the original dropseek protocol the
encapsulation process is handled
entirely on the nadia machine
and i'm going to talk about the nadia
machine because this is actually what
we've been using
um as part of the workflow for the the t
cells i'm going to talk about there's no
need to set pump speeds or any
complicated pump spread um
setup like you would do with the the
original drop seek method
the encapsulation is very simple you
have a stream of oil
uh a stream of beads decorated with
oligonucleotides that capture rna
this buffer also contains lysis solution
and separately you have a stream of
cells
so once the cells encounter the lysis
buffer and the bead they lies release
their rna and then it captured within
the bead
the library is prepared as per the
original dropseek protocol
um i think donna might bio now have a
modified simple protocol to increase
yield
which actually we don't use in our lab
primarily because we have this working
quite well and i
don't really want to change things when
things are working
then the sample is then sequenced
analyzed and i'll go on to this in
subsequent slides of how we analyze our
data
so the design of the bead is important
for this method to work
and then it basically follows the the
original costco
2015 paper you have a built
a bead built up in the five prime to
three prime directions you can
capture the three prime rna polyacide
then all downstream chemistry is then
performed on the bead
which includes a barcode that allows you
to link the reed back to
a per cell and a unique molecular
identifier so then you can
which is specific to every individual
rna and then computationally you can
work out which rna belongs to which cell
and then remove pcr duplicates using the
umi
so i often see single cell sequencing
methods actually used on projects which
don't need
single cell sequencing requirements um
the first question that i always ask is
do i actually need to run a single cell
experiment and
will a bulk rna-seq actually give me a
better transcriptional resolution and
actually it'll be way more statistically
robust than a single cell experiment
and plus it's going to be a lot less
expensive
single cell sequencing however is used
best when it's used to address
specific scientific questions related to
heterogeneity lineage tracing or
studying cells through a dynamic
stochastic event
the most important factor and something
that i find quite often gets neglected
is that people leave the most important
but
how the question how you analyze their
data
at the point when they've generated
their data um
this question really should be addressed
first thing
um because if you don't have the
expertise within your lab to analyze
this data then you need to find
solutions to overcome this
and if you get computational people on
involved early on
they can help inform how best to set up
a single cell experiment to involve
things like batch effects and get the
most out of your sequencing experiment
note of caution on using commercial
computational approaches is that
really you need some expertise because
these computational analysis tools will
always give you an answer at the end of
it and it might not always be the right
one
so dropseek was actually initially
analyzed using a set of dropsic
tools by the mccarral lab um these have
actually been
nicely written up into this dropseek
pipe um
snakemake pipeline i ran this pipeline
and it does a really nice job
however i've personally moved away from
drop seek tools
because the field has moved on
considerably since 2015.
my preferred approach is something
called pseudoalignment instead of heavy
computational mapping approach of dropsy
tools
you're actually aligning to a
transcriptome which makes the whole
process less computationally expensive
fast and more accurate than a
traditional mapping approach
there are two implementations of pseudo
pseudo-alignment this is callisto bus
tools
and salmon alavin um if you want to
learn more about pseudo-alignment i
recommend you looking at the brey
italian method who
really laid this out quite nice and very
beautifully
but what you tool to use and so i've
been benchmarking callisto
and salmon um and what i find is there's
a slight
increase in the precision and recall
with bus tools
callisto however in real life there's
actually no
overall population change between the
two methods
um and i think the differences are quite
negligible really so
i really think that here because
consistency is key
don't change the way you process your
data halfway through processing some of
your samples
keep it all the same personally i choose
bus tools at the moment that was only
purely because it was convenient at the
time
and i saw a slight increase in the
benchmarking in terms of the accuracy
overall our single cell workflow is as
follows we use pseudoalignment to align
our reads to the transcriptome and then
use bus tools to generate counts of
cells
by genes quality control is a real big
issue and is key here
um and i use the skater r package as
well as bespoke scripts to quantitate
quality check all of the data
i spend probably 70 of my time just
quality checking data before actually
doing any downstream analysis
all of these analytic their statistical
and
these statistics are then added to an
sqlite relational database along with
any metadata associated with the
experiment
this database can handle millions of
cells and it actually scales
really well so the workflow can scale
from thousands up to millions of cells
that
actually i'm working on quite regularly
now
then downstream analysis such as doublet
identification single off classification
and visualization of disney or umaps are
then
performed and then visualized my
preferred method is cell by gene
by the transit berg initiative
so we typically use scan pi or surat for
our downstream analysis
as well as bespoke scripts and really
the tool that i use
largely depends on the complexity of the
project and the numbers of cells
i'm slowly for larger projects c-rat and
r-based methods just don't scale
and you need a scanpi development is
what we're analyzing most of our data
sets in because this scales very nicely
to millions of cells um so the lab
workflows are
if you're interested at all on get and
the suit alignment
runs remarkably fast um and
otherwise um if you i still would
recommend
dropseek pipe if you don't um
want to use any pseudo-alignment
approaches that's
equally and in fact actually a really
nice um snake make pipeline
so now we come to the science aspect and
specifically how i'm using single cell
biology in um to answer some scientific
questions specifically within
epigenetics
the first thing that i'd like to
emphasize is really how we use single
cell primarily
single cell sequencing is really just a
tool that should be used
within the wider scientific concept
context of your other
scientific tools so the technology has
actually really now matured
in both the wet lab and the
computational side so much that we
actually now run it very routinely
almost every day
therefore single cell should be used
within the wider context
and therefore the first experiment i
always ask myself as i mentioned at the
beginning of the talk do i actually
really need to run the single cell
sequencing experiment
so the main considerations for running
or not running a single cell sequencing
experiment largely come down to
heterogeneity how heterogeneous how
heterogeneous or how variable you think
your tissue or cell population is
are you working or are you wanting to
study a dynamic process and how variable
are your treatments conditions
will ultimately improve
or you'll get a better chance of using
single cell
sequencing technologies to understand
this heterogeneity within your tissue
specifically looking at identifying
composition changes
or differential expression between the
different subsets within your experiment
so our typical laboratory laboratory
workflow in the group is
we use chemical and biology
with knockdown or knockout screening
approaches to identify
targets within cellular systems
i then leverage this with information
and identification from molecular
mechanisms
underpinning these effects using a
combination of the latest
diagnostic techniques such as bulk rna
sequencing single cell transcriptomics
site of single cell proteomics and very
basic biochemical
assays what we're doing with these tools
is trying to build a consensus to answer
a specific mechanistic scientific
question
we leverage all of this mechanistic
insight with disease biology
and i have incredibly very effective
clinical collaborators that make
translating our basic scientific
findings into
disease relevant biology and very
painless so the project
that i'm going to talk about today
started from a small
molecule epigenetic inhibitor screen
that was performed on th17 cells
we work very closely with the structural
genomics consortium within the
university of oxford and thus expertise
lie within crystallography and
developing small molecule epigenetic
inhibitors
to inhibit the epigenetic machinery we
then use these libraries of inhibitors
within simple screens
so we now have a collection of libraries
that target the epigenome
metabolome ubiquitous and proteostasis
pathways
that are curated by professor uda
oberman also within the the partner
research center these small
molecule probe libraries are curated
and then they are constantly updated and
expanded
and then used within assays
so we used our library of inhibitors
um we tend to when we use our library
inhibitors we tend to choose very simple
readouts that are key
to a particular aspect of biology that
we're interested in
i have a long-term standing interest in
t-cell biology and particularly
interested in identifying epigenetic
pathways that regulate
t-cell inflammatory function
specifically il-17 cytokine expression
in th17 cells as these are the key
players in the pathogenicity of
autoimmune diseases such as ankylosing
spondyloarthritis it was clear from
these screens that we observed a number
of hits associated with jumanji histon
dimethylases specifically one inhibitor
called gskj4 gskj4 is an inhibitor of
the
jmjd3 utx histone dimethylases
and these regulate h3k27
trimethylation so they remove the
methylation marks
so gmg 83 therefore if you inhibit this
what you should expect to see is an
increase in h3k27 me3
which is what we're showing here um on
the chipseek
um in the graph the red and the blue
we can see that there's a global
increase in the deposition of this mark
once you inhibit gmj83
so the compound is having its effect
we initially started our investigations
into understanding the role of gskga4
and its roles specifically within th17s
using a single cell mass cytometry
cytoph approach
societal is a variation of flow
cytometry
in which antibodies are labeled with
heavy metal iron tags
and rather than fluorochromes you can
then
read these heavy metals using a
time-of-flight mass spectrometry and
reuse the helios system
from fluidine we were able to show
that 24 hours of culture with gskj4
on th17 cells led to a significant
reduction in the numbers of
pro-inflammatory cytokines
within th17 cells interestingly we also
observed a significant reduction in cell
cycle with the cells essentially stalled
in g1
phase to further investigate some of
these findings
and identify other functional
consequences of inhibiting gmj83
utx we performed bulk transcriptomics
this revealed a significant change in
the genes regulating metabolisms within
t
cells specifically the induction of a
transcriptional program that controls
tca and metabolic pathways
in order to investigate the metabolic
functions further we next
undertook detailed metabolomic profiling
with metabolon
gsk and confirmed a significant amino
acid starvation response
mirroring the transcriptional response
we were seeing
we found reductions in several tca
metabolites and observed that
mitochondrial function was also reduced
potentially in part explaining the
reduction in cytokine production
so epigenetics acts at the single cell
level and we wanted to evaluate the
precise effect of gskj4
on individual cells within the th17
cells from patients from ankylosing
spondylitis
despite what we expected to see when we
isolated these th17 cells we expected to
see them as a whole
more of a homogeneous population at the
baseline
but actually we observed significant
heterogeneity within those cells
at dmso control when we inhibited
when we added the inhibitor to these
cells we observed significant
differential gene expression
and we also perform time courses so we
can actually study this in more detail
and we found that we actually got a
transcriptional program which is very
similar to our bulk rna sequencing
however we could see a very nice
clear difference in the cell populations
uh how the cells are reacting between
the populations following
gskj4 inhibition
um one thing we could nicely observe was
there was a clear separation between our
dmso and j4 treated th17s
with a clear down regulation in the
expression of many genes
again corroborating what we saw at the
bulk rna-seq level
but single-cell rna-seq actually allowed
us to have more granularity over this
and specifically look into the
individual populations in a lot more
detail
when you cluster all of our single cells
you can see that
um gskj4 has a very significant effect
on both the highly inflammatory
il-17 and interferon gamma-producing
cells
in addition to a reduction in markers
associated with memories so we're
getting a
down regulation of a memory phenotype of
th17 cells
one investigation observation that we
identified using our single cell
sequencing data which we didn't identify
during the bulk rna seq
was that we observed a clear role for
the kinetico which supported our
previous functional findings that cell
cycle was actually significantly
affected
and this indicates that gskj4 regulates
cell cycle in a manner that
is kinetic core dependent and actually
we're currently investigating this up in
more detail
um as single cell technology has matured
and the method has become more routine
and i think
one of the things that you really also
have to think about is that repeats
also very important i typically see
quite a lot of variability
within single cell repeats
thankfully in this experiment we didn't
see any
significant variability between the
different treatments and
the different repeats from the different
samples but
from analyzing lots of single cell
sequencing data sets this
actually is an issue and it should
really be a consideration whenever you
set up any single cell sequencing
experiments
so because we have per sample
transcriptome information
um one single cell tool that i actually
find really useful for studying biology
is the application of trajectory
inference or cedar time
trajectory inference has a um
it's actually radically enhancing single
cell research by
enabling the study of a dynamic change
in gene expression
in what we would call a pseudotime
so i've used trajectory inference to
determine the pattern
of a dynamic process experienced
by our th17 cells in this case
i've modeled pseudotime through as a
function of t
cell differentiation and then the cells
are then arranged based on the
progression
of this process so the idea is that
co-regulated gene expression changes
can then um be determined and mapped
back to the biology associated with
culturing gsk j4
so i use monocle 2 here and i was able
to
observe that dmso and j4 sat at
opposite ends of the th17
differentiation trajectory
using this trajectory analysis we see
that t cell receptor signaling is
significantly impacted by gsk j4
and furthermore um we also identified
that gskj4
may be affecting alternative splicing
and this is actually something that i'm
now following
up using long read single cell
nanopore sequencing which is a method
that currently in developing which i
won't be going on
to talked about today
another tool that researchers can find
useful is rna velocity
which is a high dimensional vector that
predicts the future state of
individual cells on a time scale of
hours
so using this tool we wanted to see if
we could predict the effects of
gskj4 had on our phenotype and where the
cells would
migrate to unfortunately the
interpretation of this tool in this
context is actually quite difficult
because we saw
large predicted rna velocities
however there was a major trajectory
flow towards the center of the plot
which focuses on the low il17 producing
cells
and so it wasn't really that useful in
this context but it has been in
in other contexts that i've used this in
so inhibiting uh these are the
conclusions for this aspect
inhibiting gmg83 utx with gskj4
results in a reduction in inflammatory
function in th17 cells
single cell sequencing has allowed us to
investigate the dynamic relationship
between gsk4 treatment and th17 subsets
and i think the stress that i want to
make is that actually we've learned
novel biology
as a consequence of using single cell
sequencing that
i just wouldn't be able to have
understood
if i had taken just a bulk rna-seq
approach
so i want to spend the last or the next
five minutes
or so going through other projects that
i've been using single cell sequencing
in
and specifically laying out a few
lessons that i've learned which
may hopefully be useful for any of you
wanting to undertake a single cell
sequencing experiments yourself
so one area that i researched that i
work in heavily is in multiple myeloma
of bone cancer
we're using single cell sequencing to
evaluate drug responses
in bone marrow of drug resistant
multiple myeloma patients
the reason i'm mentioning this is to
actually highlight that
sample treatment and handling is
something that actually really needs to
be thought of a lot
because we see actually quite a lot of
the time it takes to impact
the time it takes to process cells from
these bone marrows from the clinic
actually has a major impact on
the ultimately the sample sequencing
quality
however other types of experiments you
also have to have
other have other considerations and
these experiments
for instance still in the myeloma field
we've been injecting mice with tumor
cells
and then tracking that migration within
a mouse model
we isolate the bone marrows from these
mice and then we process the cells
the consideration for this experiment
was how to effectively streamline
all of the processes so that all of the
mice can be culled and processed in a
very time efficient
and dependent manner because again if
you don't think about these things
before you start the experiment
you're really going to come into quite a
significant issues
in the long term downstream
so the last example i want to provide is
the work that i'm doing in
collaboration with the tendency network
where we've been isolating cells and
nuclei
from really really challenging acellular
tissue
from tendons so this is part of the
human cell atlas project
on the left you can see a very rich
supraspinatus superspinatus
tendon um it's very cellular
cellular rich however on the right you
can see that this is a hamstring which
has got a very low cell
composition one of the things that i've
realized
or we have realized sorry is that sample
isolation procedures
need to be adapted for each individual
tissue to yield optimal cell numbers
or nuclei numbers uh for example if you
don't get this right
you can end up getting a lot of debris
within your sample
and this is seen here um if you see on
the right
the person holding the two tubes the
right tube is very cloudy
um this is despite all of the nuclei
lies defectively um
unfortunately there's just a lot of
debris and this can actually clog
microfluidics if you don't remove it
so the way we we're taking to get around
this is actually to
first of all modify cell isolation
procedures
but also fact sorting if it's un if
you're not able to remove this debris
um you can see that lots of debris
actually has an impact on
the ability of the microfluidics to
capture
um your cells and this is on the left
and you can see you're not getting that
many features of rna and not that many
counts however
with removing this debris we can
actually get
very very uh good quality rna-seq data
so the overall conclusions for this um
aspect is that project planning is
really really important
get someone who's done a single select
uh sequencing experiment on board early
they can give you lots of insight so you
don't make mistakes
again i see lots of people
using single cell sequencing when it's
really not needed
and again a computational strategy is
incredibly important to think about
before starting
get someone who can analyze the data on
early on board
and they'll also help you um develop
the computation the um
strategy for setting up the experiment
um and with that um
the last thing i want to mention is that
suspension cells are really easy
um however tissue is a lot more
complicated and involved
with that i'd like to thank um
all of those who've been involved
particularly um working
in my group or within collaborations and
this is particularly uder oppermann
um martin philpot sarah snelling and the
rest of the tendency network plus many
many others
um as well as the funders for many of
the projects
and with that i'm going to finish and
pass that on to i think the
last slide
thank you dr ayers dr sajak and dr cribs
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many of your questions
as we have time for okay
our first question get my questions up
what is the minimum number of cells
needed for a
typical single cell experiment
so i can answer this on the um
probably the statistical side and this
is a question that i get asked
regularly by many many people and it's
not an easy
question to address a lot of the time
because it really needs an understanding
of your underlying heterogeneity that
you see within the sample and
specifically
the smallest cell population that you
want to measure
for instance i do quite a lot of work on
cancer and some of the times you just
don't
get the numbers of cancer cells
required to get enough statistical power
to work out statistical power there's
now quite a lot of very good
single cell power calculations that you
can do which you
first of all generate pilot data and
then you can feed that
data into the power calculations i think
maybe tom might want to answer this on
terms of the hardware
yeah absolutely i'd love to add
something on the hardware side there
um of course experimental design does
come first and i think adam's done a
great job of
talking about all that kind of thing um
but in terms of
the absolute cell numbers per sample
that can go into the nadia machine which
is what i can talk about
our standard single cell rna-seq
protocol
suggests a starting number of cells per
sample of 75
000 however due to the fact that the
nadia is a very versatile machine
we can not only change all of those
parameters that i was talking about
previously
we can also bring the amount of input
from that standard amount of 250
microliters
down to around 100 microliters
which means at the same cell
concentration we can go from 75 000
down to around thirty thousand cells so
that's what i'd say per sample is the
recommended
minimum cell input um on the nadia
platform
obviously you can also go lower uh per
sample if you're using technique
such as cell hashing as some customers
are
in order to load multiple samples into a
single
cartridge or chip i think that
explains it okay great thank you
got another question if you have debris
within your sample
what's the best approach to remove that
debris
um so i can ask that uh answer that
question the first thing is actually
getting your
your protocol optimized to try and
minimize the debris in the first place
and this can actually be done
by modifying the different types of
buffers that you have
um because what we found
is you can get away with some amount of
debris within that sample
as long as the debris is small enough
the problem that we found when
working with tendon is a tendon tissue
is the worst tissue i've
ever had to work with in my entire life
it's acellular it
feels like that horrible grisly
um bait that you get on steaks that you
never want to eat
um so you try and
you have to really get the methods
optimized because those
sam those tissues produce long stringy
bits that basically just block the
fluidics and so
the best approach we found the ideal is
facts
sorting but unfortunately fact sorting
has all sorts downsides
because you also lose either nuclei or
material cells
just because you're not ever going to
get 100 deficiency in the the fat
sorting
we have had experience with removing
dead cells using a dead cell removal kit
but the experience the
the um there's been issues with that
in terms of it doesn't really clean
everything up 100
i think um leading on from adam's point
as well on a hardware basis it's worth
me mentioning at this point that
um generally blockages of
the nadia microfluidic chip are not
occurring due to cells
generally that can be from overloading
of beads or various different things
and that comes from the fact that the
nadia junction itself and the nadia
filter the smallest
point that basically the cells have to
flow through is
um so the smallest point there is around
50 microns across
which means that unlike maybe some other
microfluidic platforms that may have a
13 micron aperture
um it is more tolerable to for example
large cell sizes
so i noticed they're adam you're also
working as well as tendons with some
myocardium perhaps or that kind of cell
where you get very very long
multi-nucleated cells we do have some
users who are also able to run those
very large cells on the nadia platform
as well
but obviously it's all due to exactly
how you
how well you get rid of that debris in
the first place
thank you so much we've got another
question
one of the crucial steps in my
experience is having high quality cells
how do you make sure the cells you get
from clients are of high quality
do you provide a kit for isolation to
ensure quality standards
so i could ask just i could maybe
respond generally and then maybe tom can
can um talk about the nadia
uh for me um this is
one of the issues that i find constantly
um
is is the biggest problem is actually
and it stems from
i think getting very good live
cells or good nuclei from an experiment
and really the only best approach the
best quality data that we've got
is always tends to come from a fax
sorted based
method if it's not single cells for
suspension from blood it's very easy
we don't have any issues the the issue
that we see a lot of the time is when
they're more difficult
to um to extract or they clump
or for instance um
yeah fact sorting or trying to remove
that debris is
i can only suggest
and also minimizing sorry the last thing
is minimizing the time it takes to do
the experiment is actually really
important
um sorry that's a mess no
please please um so you did touch on an
excellent point though
um where always consider that if you
have a tissue that's difficult
to dissociate without turning it to mush
and just
making all the mrna from dead cells go
everywhere if that's the difficulty
always consider that there is the
possibility of single nucleus rna
sequencing
where are you granted there are
differences between a nuclear
transcriptome
and the host cellular transcriptome but
if
it's the difference between getting a
good
s-nuke seek run and a kind of rubbish
single cell isolate you can consider the
snoop squeak in that case and that is
the standard
um stand operating protocol on the nadia
okay thank you i've got another question
why does nadia innovate require
nadia instrument
um so that is due to the fact that the
nadia
innovate is an add-on module that
doesn't have pressure pumps in it
so what it does is it hijacks the
pressure pumps from the nadia
and using tubes which are attached to
the
to a special breakout cartridge we then
take that pressure and
pump it through into a single chip that
we can look at
using that microscope because we only
have one microscope you can only look at
one
chip at a time so you might as well just
do one at a time
but basically what that is is it's
taking the
internal computer brain from the nadia
and the pumps
and using them uh instead of having to
have a whole new system basically that's
why it's an add-on
and that what that means is an extension
is that any
protocol that can be developed on the
innervate can always
be ported back onto the nadia to be run
in full throughput
so whilst you can play around with one
sample at a time once you're done with
playing around
that can go back into eighteen of the
mode four sample mode
and maybe if i can also add to this for
someone who's actually been using so
we got both the nadia and the nadi
innovate together
um the nadia innovate sat on the bench
for six months and we thought
well what we've got no reason for this
why did we get it
until actually we started to realize the
utility of it and
we developing our own methods and adding
different buffer compositions
um has made the innovate method actually
a godsend because it allows us to do a
lot more i.e
you know we've got these really
difficult nuclei and cells we're
changing the cell buffers
to actually accommodate those different
experiments and it's it's
actually really been very very useful um
for something that sat on the bench for
six months not knowing what to do with
it
um we use it probably more than the
actual nadia
itself
that's good to hear um and i mean if
you'd like to read a little bit more
about
basically a show case of step step
guides
of the kind of situation where you might
use the innervate very heavily you can
take a look at our
plant protoplast application note on our
website where we've shown how you go
from
okay here's a difficult cell type with a
very difficult buffer very sticky
plant buffers and you need to somehow
get that into droplets
it goes in great detail through the
process of creating
a new pressure profile and of creating a
whole new
scrnac for your special self-sign
all right thank you i have another
question
i would be very interested on the
experimental design
of the j4 dmso single cell experiment
how did you overcome batch's batches
issues when comparing two conditions
um so the great thing about the
nadia system um compared to the old
dropseek where you would have to run a
sample at a time
in series actually you can analyze the
you i think we didn't tend to run four
cartridges but i think the maximum is
eight
so maybe um yeah i think it's eight um
that allows you to do lots of samples in
parallel so to avoid any batch effects
um we always run controls with
our treatments and it's really it's
getting the controls correct in an
experiment that really gives you
the ability to directly compare because
i've
i've worked on single cell data for
probably about
five well quite many years now and in
the old
days where you couldn't really do
or overcome these batch effects some of
the batch effects were horrific and
there was lots of computational
strategies to minimize
and get over this but ultimately a batch
correction is a fudge
um it's a sometimes a necessary fudge
but if you can run your samples in
parallel that gives you a lot more
um they're not confounded essentially
great well um that's all the time we
have for questions today
i want to remind our audience that those
questions we were unable to answer and
those that come in during the on-demand
period
will be answered by our speakers via the
email address that you provided at the
time of registration
so thanks again dr ayers dr sajak and dr
cribbs
do you have any final comments for our
audience
no other than it's been a pleasure to
work with you adam and we hope that your
ongoing uh efforts to make sort of new
and interesting protocols on the
innovation come to fruition
yeah same spin
okay and i just wanted to mention that
well it's been a pleasure working with
with all of you and thank you so much to
all the the entire audience for taking
time to join us at this webinar
and lastly we hope to see you at our
next webinar happening
in november where we will dig more into
the data
analysis part so thank you very much
all right thank you so much and before
we go i'd like to thank the audience
again
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
um and again questions we didn't have
time for and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers
via the contact information you provided
we would like to once again thank our
speakers for their time today and for
their important research
and we'd like to thank lab roots and our
sponsors illumina and dolomite bio for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
time
when it's available for replay please
join us in our upcoming webinar
analyze your single cell rna-seq data
from raw reads to insights
that's all for now until next time
goodbye